and we can see this is the question do
people feel that Ed Miliband is ready to
govern and back in the summer 22%
thought so now only thirteen percent
what about his competition how does he
compare well if we look at the net
satisfaction rating for Ed Miliband you
can see that he's at minus forty four
percent that is the lowest of any leader
of any party since this kind of data was
gathered compare that to nick clegg he's
at minus thirty six percent which is not
too good either David Cameron is on
minus fifteen percent and thorn in all
their size Nigel Farage the most popular
leader of the parties at the moment how
worrying is this and less than six
months from an election well if you look
at how other leaders were doing it
around about the same time so six months
before the general election in nineteen
eighty sorry 1992 we had this 1991
rating eight percent of people at sorry
minus eight percent net satisfaction
rating then for Gordon Brown minus
twenty five percent that was before the
2010 election and then Michael foot-
thirty-eight percent before he lost a
landslide victory against Margaret
Thatcher off the back of the Falklands
War ed Miliband doing worse than all of
them though on minus twenty-four percent
minus forty four percent and in terms of
how that translates I'm in sugar and
Moon are saying the polls don't matter
what matters is how people vote voting
intention what do we know about that so
far yeah well if you look at the parties
rather than the leaders themselves it's
still not looking very good for labor
according to this latest poll so for the
Conservatives there that's the best
result thirty-two percent that they've
had since David Cameron came into power
for labor that's looking back to how
things were under Gordon Brown the
Liberal Democrats nine percent there you
Kip fourteen percent and the Green Party
doing really well in this poll on seven
percent so looking at two minor parties
holding twenty percent twenty one
percent of the overall vote according to
this part yeah and the key thing is who
are they taking that vote from exactly i
mean you can look at this two ways fred
melbourne one is he's been in power now
for had the leadership now for four
years and
you know he's not doing well enough but
his way of looking at it is well look we
still got six months to go we haven't
yet had the whole focus of an actual
election campaign let's see where we are
in six months time okay jason powell
thank you very much indeed